[Music]
thanks everybody welcome to the Pete
Holmes show we are a new TV show unless
this is a rerun if you're watching this
in 2018 in which case whoa I'm from the
past but here in the present this is a
new show which can be intimidating but
can also be liberating people always
talk about how hard it is to transfer to
a new job or a new school or move to a
new town but I say it's great what an
opportunity to reboot your life the way
they reboot movies you know I mean
goodbye Keaton Batman hello
Kilmer Batman if weif is a video game
being thrust into a new environment is
like putting in a quarter and getting a
new guy you know I mean back at your old
job everyone knew you and they knew you
as Steve the guy you accidentally puked
on the boss at the company cruise but
once you start your new job probably
because you got fired for accidentally
puking on your boss at the company
cruise you can be any Steve you want no
more queasy Steve now your iron stomach
Steve the guy who definitely doesn't
puke on bosses on land or at sea being
new is your chance to quickly and easily
reinvent yourself back in your old
hometown people are like why are you
suddenly wearing a fedora but if you
move to a new state no one knows you
haven't just always worn a fedora it's
like oh this this this this is my fedora
now I've been wearing it for years and
you can't prove that I haven't been cut
to you the night before running it over
a few times in your car to age its it's
brand new looking I look like Smash
Mouth
and if you're not the new guy you can't
just start rocking a Kangol hat all of a
sudden either who do you think you are
Samuel Jackson because Sammy J is the
only guy who can pull that look off from
out of the blue but if you transfer to a
new school where the out of a
Kangol hat he'll tell everyone that
Kangol had was a Bar Mitzvah gift from
samuel l.jackson Mazel Tov mother they
don't know you're not Jewish
three boot vests too hard to just start
working that upright bass player look in
the middle of your sophomore year put
that vest on in the morning that's a
tense day walking around the lunchroom
trying to act normal just look what's
happening what's happening yeah yeah oh
no just wearing a vest like it's no big
deal
yeah no sleeves that's for me pocket
pocket for a pocket watch back belt yeah
there's a back belt you know what I'm
gonna go home and change cuz I just
realized I'm not Justin Timberlake or
Ellen but if you transfer to a new
school jackpot don't be sad you have to
make new friends be glad you get to rock
a vest you could show up with an eye
patch and a parrot if you wanted to you
could be the Jack Sparrow of your chess
club just like our rook to Queen Bishop
four that's checkmate ehi okay that is a
terrible joke really bad almost a zero
studying abroad that's an opportunity to
reinvent yourself - you can go away just
for a semester you get to come back with
a British accent just like tell you with
it for months and London changes people
cheers first start here's your chance
become the Buddhist skateboarder
overnight be the goth girl who wears all
white be the Mexican rapper you can
bounce back from your divorce by
becoming a DJ just like yeah I've buried
the plane
DJ single dad here on the ones and twos
mashing up a Hootie and the Blowfish
song with a voicemail from my ex he'll
reboot it baby and if any of that sounds
impossible to you trust me it's not
thousands of people across this great
nation are doing it every day it's
called the witness protection program
sure you have to go on the lam because
you ratted on the Swedish mob but the
good news is now you get to wear a vest
and a Kangol hat
[Music]